Where does this come from and why does
gas Zions not have gas moves?
Wow,
that is a great question.
Wow.
First of all,
I was alive when people to figure it out
or satisfied themselves as where our
moon came from.
And uh,
it's generally agreed that our moon was
created when the earth was hit with
another pretty big thing,
another asteroid.
And uh,
the impact was very hard,
very hard.
And the energy of the smashing was
converted to heat and both the earth and
the moon were hot and molten and they
both cooled off.
And here we are with this other separate
thing in orbit around us.
Now,
why the gas giants not have gas moons is
a great question.
And the answer is almost certainly
because of gravity.
So when you have these little things
that spun off of,
let's see,
Jupiter or Saturn,
they were too small to sustain
themselves as just balls of gas.
The gas shrunk down and gravity pulled
it down and formed a solid thing.
Whereas in Jupiter and Saturn,
there's so much,
uh,
spin,
so much heat created that they're held,
uh,
in the gaseous state.
Or what we would call gaseous state by
the energy that's coming out of them,
whereas the smaller ones cooled off so
much that they turned solid.
It's just a fantastic question.
Aria and astrophysicists or planetary
scientists speculate about this all the
time,
but what a fantastic thing that you made
this observation,
the moons of Jupiter,
the big ones I owes Calista,
um,
uh,
Europa and Ganymede,
those big moons are cooled off.
They're not,
they're not gaseous like Jupiter that
whom they or what the orbit.
That's fantastic.
Wow.
And maybe more will be learned about
this and I gotta tell Ya,
Aria,
it's very reasonable that in your
lifetime we will send the right
spacecraft to Europa and the moon of
Saturn and sell it us and Titan and look
for signs of life instead of being a gas
giant.
In this one example,
Europa is a moon of Jupiter that is,
uh,
has twice as much seawater as the earth
and that water is under a layer of ice.
And I mentioned it because it's evidence
of how things cool off when they're in
space and they're small or relatively
small,
the ice forms.
Because of the heat of,
of creation,
the thing smashed together.
That heat is radiated into space.
So there's a crust of ice,
but the water underneath is kept liquid
by the gravitational exercising of its
orbit around Jupiter.
It's amazing what an Observation Aria,
you're making my day.
I hope you will be involved in missions
to Europa and you will look for signs of
life below the ice.
I mean,
who knows?
If you have an ocean for four and a half
billion years,
things are going to happen.
It could be living things.
There could be your opinions out there.
Fish people that you'll interact with.
Keep us posted.
Thank you.